[Musique]
quand est-ce que vous avez su qu'il
était homosexuel et villemomble il ya
quatre ans bien sûr 24 ans bonjour qui
nous invitait chez lui et enfin on
allait passer une bonne journée puis
tout d'un coup il met limoges a parfois
quelque chose je suis attiré par les
hommes ça m'a fait un effet son royaume
est parti en claquant la porte je les
suis dit ce que je pensais qu'ils
étaient pas très gentil mais enfin j'ai
dit ce que je pensais plus fait dans
certains cas d'anciens je pensais que
qui prend le temps c'est qu'il est et en
mange passe quelque chose d'épouvantable
c'est un fils et j'ai particulière tout
ensemble tant que les plus riches en
partie schéma qu'elle aurait causés par
la suite de jeunes beaucoup mais
beaucoup beaucoup de mal à
[Musique]
vous avez quel âge 33 dont
et quels métiers faites vous le
chauffeur poids lourds dans une
entreprise confort routier
est ce que vous avez toujours été
homosexuel
toujours
plus moi je me rappelle est
exclusivement enfin je fais une
expérience avec une femme que j'ai vécu
à quel taux maximum
ce n'a pas ça marchait pas
vous auriez préféré exa marche
chaque pas maintenant
maintenant vous vivez comment
avec un petit ami spoliés oui bien sûr
pour lui est complètement avec lui comme
ouvrier avec une femme
ça vous ennuie pas l'idée que vous
n'aurez pas d'enfant c'est un peu mou
vous auriez pu en avoir un laraque avec
la fac techniquement
ça lui a laissé un mauvais souvenir non
pas d'une expérience ça n'a pas
dans le milieu dans lequel vous vivez je
suppose qu'on peut pas dire ces choses
là bas c'est pas tellement
si vous le disiez qu'est ce qui
arriverait les insultes
montre un peu du devoir
et l'impatience dans ce milieu même il y
en a d'autres que vous
je pense je peux pas être
[Musique]
est ce qu'il y à un type de mots
sexuelle au nom non pas du tout rires on
y trouvera du tout il y as l'homophilie
bien agir en tant que tel et c'est celle
qui est poursuivie parfois part de
certaines lois dans certains pays par la
société d'ailleurs aussi mais il y as je
crois autant d'hommes fils qu'il ya
justement de mon fils il y a bien sûr
les pédérastes déjà qu'ils sont une
variante dans l'homophilie et pour qui
bien sûr la vie est particulièrement
pénible douloureuse à transmettre ce
qu'ils aiment les jeunes garçons ceux
qui aiment les jeunes enfants les jeunes
garçons les adolescents les impubère ou
les pubs r on les appelle pédéraste
pédophiles etc il y à l'homo fils
qui est donc bien dans sa peau qui sur
le plan sexuel aimera le l'hétérosexuel
il ne pourra pas avoir de relation même
visite avec un homme au fil il y a le
mot file plein d' aventure de frivolité
de superficialité il ya celui au
contraire qui veut bâtir sa vie sur le
modèle presque du couple hétérosexuel
donc il n'ya pas un outil pour ma fille
alors non plus il n'ya pas le type
maniéré excentrique à la voix de caquet
à la démarche déhanchée celui qui se
fait remarquer dans la rue décolorés la
folle autrement dit entre guillemets
seul qui parait-il que je n'ai pas connu
et dieu soit loué qui florissait à paris
au cours des années 30 ou 25 non
maintenant l'effet l'homosexualité c'est
un petit peu brisé mais ce que l'opinion
croit souvent l'effet de le meux fils
excentrique et c'est faux il y a aussi
le mot sexuelle très viril et que
précisément personne ne peut reconnaître
d'où la stupéfaction parfois de certains
parents quand ils découvrent
l'homophilie de leur fils à 25 et 30 ans
ils avaient l'impression que deux parce
qu'ils avaient vu au cinéma ce qu'ils
avaient entendu des chansonniers ça
devait être obligatoirement un
excentrique et comment mon fils est
normal il est bien constitué
physiquement il travaille normalement et
il est homo c'est qu'on ne le croit pas
il serait sain très simple j'ai vécu
tout à fait normalement je suis né
normalement j'ai posé une femme normale
jean pas beaucoup le mot normal bien qui
me gêne un petit peu nos enfants et nous
savons et des enfants de très beaux
enfants jusqu'à
jusqu'à l'âge de 10 10 12 ans on tue les
enfants lorsque j'ai réalisé que je
devenais homophiles l'a dit hier je dois
venir me suis-je il n'y aurait
absolument ce que c'était ça m'est
arrivé un petit peu comme un coup de
massue quoi celui d'arrivée de la façon
suivante je m'étais intéressé
à un de mes collègues de travail qui
était un garçon tout à fait charmant qui
avait des ennuis et les ennuis de
famille j'essayais de lui être utile
de le faire remarquer car sa femme le
quittait pour donner tous ces détails et
je me suis toujours intéressé à lui que
je me suis épris de lui c'est un très
gros chèque en main très très grand jeu
parce que je me suis vu malade très
grave nouvelle alors j'ai voulu aller
trouver un psychiatre je suis allé trop
mc4 j'ai fait la psychanalyse c'était
trop long ça ne me satisfaisait pas je
suis là je prenais pour quelqu'un de
fous je perdais main raison est une
chose pareille marion c'était impossible
et ça leur est toujours de l'amour
plateau et c'était toujours de l'amour
platonique et car je luttais je pensais
que ça pourrait ne plus la map la
technique alors épuisé mais aucune issue
bien je cachais cela ma famille mes
enfants dopage ça a été un un calvaire
et tout ce que j'ai fait tout ce que
j'ai tenté pour le faire souligné n'a en
fait rien donné monsieur vous avez une
formation neurologiques vous est
consacré ensuite à l'endive
l'endocrinologie vous êtes donc eu
particulièrement qualifiée pour répondre
à cette question que tout le monde se
pose y at il un rapport entre
la physiologie et l'homosexualité 10 ont
fui logis ou physiopathologie oui
j'avoue que dans ce domaine il y a
souvent les attitudes un peu passionnel
des préjugés d'ordre moral l'esthétique
métaphysique religieux social et caetera
et dont il faut se débarrasser
pour répondre à votre question précise
se cantonner dans l'objectif pur ont
pour objectif il faut faire une enquête
alors pour l'objectif il faut réunir un
assez grand nombre de sujets pour ne pas
se laisser impressionner par tel ou tel
cas particulier je passe mon étude sur
83 cas et d'autre part il faut étudier
d'une part la morphologie de ces sujets
ben stiller différenciation sexuelle
morphologiques et éloignées ou non de la
normale et d'autre part sur des études
du biochimiques disons hormonal qui
consiste à voir si à la source il y à
une anomalie
déséquilibre hormonal à la revenons-en
aux rapports avec la forme avec la
morphologie comment avez vous procédé eh
bien il ya évidemment beaucoup
d'éléments sur lequel on se base il ya
là pour l'aspect les organes génitaux
externes qui par définition était
pratiquement normale il y à la
musculature il y à la répartition dressé
sur laquelle mon ami le professeur vague
de marseille a beaucoup insisté il y a
le système pileux le caractère de la
voix etc mais j'attache une importance
particulière à la morphologie générale
ce que j'ai défini selon le morpho g
cela consiste à prendre certaines
mesures que nous avons choisi jadis avec
monsieur nomique avec qui j'ai établi
cette technique qui consiste à d'abord
prendre un modèle le modèle ce sont de
très nombreux hommes normaux
chez lesquels nous avons pris cinq
mesures
le périmètre à 6 ou ma mère au repos la
hauteur du grand trochanter qui définit
et la longueur du monde inférieur par
rapport à la taille qui a un certain
intérêt j'ai pas le temps de développer
la taille elle-même naturellement et
surtout les deux diamètres des épaules
ou bi humérale et des hanches ou bi
troquant terriens qui marque surtout la
différenciation sexuelle on a fait
refaire en moyenne nous avons par
définition mis sur une même ligne
horizontale les moyennes mesure d'un
très grand nombre de sujets normaux
établissant ainsi le mort programme
normal ça c'est l'homme moyen par chacun
des points nous avons élevé désordonnée
avec des variations selon la taille etc
alors nous avons établi cette technique
chez nos hameaux sexuelle tout au moins
c'est la plupart d'entre eux et bien je
vous donne très brièvement les résultats
la majorité 54% pour être juste avec des
programmes vraiment très normaux avec
les écarts physiologique habituel la
preuve en est que sur cette courbe que
vous voyez ici où figurent entre et
continue le morpho gras moyens le normal
que voulait voir la moyenne des mesures
de ses 40 54 % d'homosexuels est
absolument superposables à celui de
l'homme normal
alors sur le plan biochimiques
je lui ai dit tout à l'heure on a au
fond qu'un instantané
il faut tenir compte du fait que
certains sujets je les dix ans des
névrosés et que la névrose peut
perturber leur activité hormonale c'est
une chose qui est bien connu et ensemble
finalement scientifiquement médicalement
les homosexuels seraient des hommes
comme les autres oui ce sont des hommes
comme les autres bien entendu avec leur
différend individuel il ya beaucoup
d'espèces dans la nature il ya parmi les
êtres humains des gens différents les
uns des autres c'est peut-être même ce
qui fait l'attrait de la vie et je ne
crois pas que l'on puisse
considérer comme ni des malades ni des
monstres des sujets dans le comportement
quelles que soient les raisons de ce
comportement est évidemment particulier
la touche on a des problèmes d'ordre
moral de sociologie et qui ne sont pas
notre sujet d'aujourd'hui parce qu'on
peut dire que
l'homosexualité une anomalie une
déviation des vierges gyan oui hors des
chemins tracés par la nature déviation
c'est le sens étymologique du mot
anomalie
oui un écart par rapport à laax général
de là moyenne des sujets
10 au delà de la moyenne de la péniche
aux critiques suscitées même si vous
voulez
perversion alors c'est un jugement moral
qui aimait chaptes et je crois qu'il
faut s'adresser aux psychiatres pour
voir si colog et aux sociologues et aux
moralistes pour savoir ce qu'ils en
pensent mais ce n'est pas moi domaine
d'après votre expérience qu'est ce que
c'est l'homosexualité nomos à l'usman à
dix et cela devient perversion et
névroses je n'aime pas beaucoup de
termites maladie ni perversion rihour je
dirais que
l'homosexualité est une manière d'être
qui touche tout de même un nombre
important de sujets puisqu'on estime
qu'il n'y à 10 % de l'humanité qui a des
tendances homosexuelles
dont la moitié soit 5 % pratique
réellement nos maux sexualité
et c'est à travers les conceptions
psychanalytique quand je ne suis pas
d'ailleurs
intégralement artisans que j'ai mieux
compris gp mieux les aider en somme vous
avez vécu et vous souhaitez continuer à
vivre en marge de notre société
tout à fait en marge disions que je suis
une voie sans issue une impasse une
sorte de clapiers j'entre dans dans un
ghetto où il n'ya eu une porte d'entrée
mais pas de sortie l'artiste vous vivez
votre homosexualité comme une
malédiction est ce que il n'entre pas
une part énorme de majo logies je ne
tiens pas à la vivre comme une
malédiction je respecte ces malédictions
l'homosexuel est presque toujours sinon
toujours
quelqu'un qui a vécu dans un climat
affectif qu'il pouvait peut-être dû
paraître normal mais qui en réalité
étaient gauche et là je crois qu'il faut
revenir aux sources et que c'est au
niveau
l' influence de la mer et aussi de
l'affluence du père il faut faire
remonter les causes principales de
l'homosexualité sous quelle forme et
bien fuir de la mer c'est la mère
dominatrice c'est la mère qui couve son
fils et la mère y détient toute autorité
c'est la mère qui écrase le père est
d'ailleurs plus d'homosexuels ça vient
rôle de la mère dans l'homosexualité et
d'âge fréquemment employé chez les
homosexuels celui ci dis moi quelle est
ta mère et je te dirai si tu as menée il
ya bien des enfants qui ont un père
dominateur ou une mère dominatrice et
qu'ils ne deviennent pas pour autant
beau sexuelle magie à hisser la séoune
et des grands mystères de
l'homosexualité c'est que beaucoup
peuvent passer par les mêmes conditions
éducatives les mêmes erreurs éducative
et pourtant ne pas avoir les mêmes
conséquences
on a vu des exemples sur le très
nombreux exemples de familles dans
lesquelles des garçons très proche
d'alger avec une année même ambiance
l'un est devenu homosexuel et les autres
ne sont pas devenus ça pose un problème
car il semble bien qu'il n'ait jamais
trouvé de trace au point de vue
organique au point de vue remet au namm
il y a tout de même une certaine dignité
qui je crois existe et plus j'étudie la
question de l'homosexualité
plus j'ai tendance à faire jouer un rôle
à cette inéquité cent-pour-cent a de
même affirmé à prédominance et sa
constance c'est ce que voulait
absolument démontrer que j'étais un
homme normal que c'était bon un accident
quand les faits j'étais un petit peu
fatigué et c'est terrain ils ne sont pas
arrivés je pense pas qu'ils aient eu
raison de faire tu dire cela aussi
longtemps du moins ça durerait des
années à un point tel que la vie était
assez pénible avec ma femme elle rit
toujours beaucoup d'affection pour moi
j'en avais toujours beaucoup plus réelle
j'étais homo fils ça y'a pas de problème
je le réalise est tout à fait nous avons
divorcé
après le divorce j'ai éprouvé le besoin
alors là de le lui dire ce fut une sorte
de révélation le fait que je puisse
justement me confier de cette façon là
mais il faut à la voilà pourquoi je me
suis fait soigner parce qu'évidemment la
pauvre était catastrophe est due au fait
qu'est-ce qu'il a eue imaginer les pires
choses car en définitive celle ci le feu
ne faisait plus partie des pires
qu'elles et puis ma fille alors donc ce
divorce a été presque un bien c'est dans
ce sens que il ya un mur d'écrouler un
rideau d'arracher j'ai pu me libérer je
suis comme ça c'est pas du tout du tout
ça n'enlève rien à l'affection je te
porte à l'amour que je te porte ainsi
qu'à mes enfants elle de son côté m'a
dit en effet tu as très bien fait de le
dire je ne sais pas comment j'aurais
pris la chose si tu veux l'avait dit
avant un divorce gens peut-être très mal
prise bien maintenant je comprends je
comprends les choses voyant que je
pourrais me libérer de cette façon là je
me suis libérée à tout le monde je dis
on verra bien je suis libéré à 1000
collaborateurs je me suis libéré
la maison poids hier libéré auprès de ma
famille enfin à tous les moments comme
ça me faisait du bien c'est c'était ma
solution
personne n'a changé vis-à-vis de moi je
ne pense pas avoir changé vis-à-vis qui
que ce soit personne ne m'a tourné le
dos et ce qui était pour moi une grave
maladie était devenu un état bon cet
état a duré a duré pas mal de temps
pendant quatre cinq années où j'étais à
la fois
l'homme damas si je voulais et en même
temps même temps j'étais homosexuel j'ai
donc connu sept bisexualité qui fut une
période transitoire jusqu'à en arriver
il ya quelques années à l'homosexualité
intégral je suis incapable de dire si je
referai le chemin à l'envers
il peut se produire j'allais presque
dire un miracle car en définitive
puisque je peux faire la comparaison je
souhaite que le mirage les lieux mais en
fait j'ai trouvé j'ai trouvé une sorte
d' équilibre si vous voulez surtout en
m'apercevant
les gens ne me trouve pas changé me
supportent en quelque sorte que je suis
dans certains comme appris
[Musique]